I can't advertise my work as Native
American art which it is this law is
anti-competitive and the purpose of it
and the effect of it is to discriminate
against Native American art from other
states it flips on its head the whole
concept of truth in advertising
Peggy Fontenot began her native our
career decades ago working in beading
silver jewelry and photography when I
started photographing I thought that
people ruined my photographs and then I
realized that the people were the
stories and that they made the
photograph she's a part of the paddle
woman tribe and has built a career that
has taken her everywhere I travel all
over the country selling my work I show
at different museum shows for four years
I did the jewelry for the Kathy Ireland
Sports Illustrated swimsuit calendars I
felt it was a real honor to be included
everything was going great with her
career that was until 2016 when a new
law passed in Oklahoma and changed her
entire world members this is House bill
2261 it provides safeguards for Native
American artists and for the collectors
of native Indian art that state
representative Chuck Hoskin the writer
of the bill the new law made it so only
people from federally recognized tribes
could call themselves native artists
Peggy belongs to a state recognized
tribe and so thanks to this new Oklahoma
law she can no longer market her art as
Native American in Oklahoma that's
fonteneau's attorney honest Asia Bowden
with the Pacific Legal Foundation she's
representing Fontenot on a lawsuit
against the state saying the new law
violates fonts and has free speech
rights to call every state recognized
tribe fake and illegitimate is just
broad sweeping and wrong she could also
face fines or imprisonment if she
describes her work as she always has I
can still sell my work in Oklahoma but I
can't advertise it as Native American
made which it is that's actually the
whole point of the law is to narrow the
universe of people who can describe
particular art as American Indian art
Clark Neely is a vice president of the
libertarian think-tank the Cato
Institute and spent 17 years as an
attorney at the public interest law firm
the Institute for justice very clearly
some group of people
want to prevent other people from using
that terminology presumably because it
has some value in the marketplace
Oklahoma is central to Native American
artists they put on some of the biggest
Native American art shows in the country
each year Peggy goes to the red earth
festival where thousands of people come
to either show their art or to see
Native American art Peggy will miss out
on earning a living in Oklahoma she
makes her money by going to these art
shows she's really upset because she
thinks that this is free speech and
she's not able to truthfully call
herself what she is it completely
undercuts and flips on its head the
whole concept of truth in advertising my
beadwork and my work isn't going to have
the same importance if it's not being
marketed as what it is which is Native
American Hoskin declined our interview
request but he said in a statement we
have seen people time and time again
falsely claimed heritage in order to
market themselves as Native artists and
this closes a loophole in the federal
act here in Oklahoma protecting Oklahoma
Indian artists Rebecca Tennant is a
harvard law professor who studies truth
in advertising law she says it may have
been poorly crafted but the Oklahoma law
was well intentioned I think they were
interested in the same basic question as
the federal government was which is how
can people sell this stuff and how can
they be truthful about what it is touch
that says that sellers misrepresenting
their products is a significant problem
in the native art world and that a
federal law that defines a native artist
more broadly has done some good the
reason at least the federal law was
enacted was a fair amount of fraud on
the market which was doing harm to
legitimate artisans for example five
people were indicted in july 2017 after
being accused of importing and selling
fake native american jewelry from the
philippines the five suspects are
accused of violating the indian arts and
crafts act but Bowden says the purpose
of the Oklahoma law is to restrict
competition
this law is anti-competitive and the
purpose of it and the effect of it is to
discriminate against Native American art
from other states they want to sell
their art and if they can limit the
number of people who can compete
with them in that space then presumably
you limit competition you expect prices
to go up it's simple economics
federally recognized tribes are big
constituency in Oklahoma and Hosken
isn't just the author of the bill he's
also served as the chief of staff for
the Cherokee Nation and of course the
Cherokees are a federally recognized
tribe and certainly would have an
interest in putting a law on the books
that says that only federally recognized
tribes can call themselves Native
American the five big federally
recognized tribes did officially come
out in support of the State against
Fontenot for me to come out by myself
and challenge these tribes I definitely
feel that I'm up against the world if
you will businesses or even individuals
who are facing competition have
essentially two ways to come out ahead
one is to up their own game or you can
go to the government and try to sandbag
your competitors I've seen this kind of
thing over and over again whether it's
organic food or interior designers or
catfish it is now the case that of the
2,500 different species of catfish in
the world you can only sell in America
one particular fish as catfish and
that's the North American channel
catfish why because that's the kind that
we raise here in America and the people
who raise that fish when you got a law
passed that says that's the only kind
you can call a catfish fonteneau's
lawyers are able to stop the enforcement
of the law temporarily so that she and
artists like her could continue to show
their art and state hb2 261 is still in
the books though so it isn't a permanent
solution yet if we're not successful in
this wall stands and it goes to other
states at the end of the day I'm still
India
you
[Music]